hello welcome to the program and we
begin in occupied east jerusalem
where an al jazeera reporter is now in
custody after being arrested by
israeli security forces
this is the footage that we have of
jivara baderi
uh being beaten and then arrested in the
neighborhood of
chefchaora she'd been doing live reports
on al jazeera's arabic channel
throughout
the day of course that neighborhood
in occupied east jerusalem that's been
really a flash point of tensions
in in recent days weeks months there has
been tension there
over plans to forcibly evict palestinian
families
now from occupied east jerusalem and so
very disturbing image the order of
jivara pleading to be left alone not to
be touched
where is she now
well she is still in that police station
just here behind me
uh in occupied east jerusalem she's been
there for
a couple of hours at least if not more
we spoke to her lawyer he managed to see
her
she complained that she had pain in her
left
side she said that she while
in the car while she was sitting in the
police car being
taken here to the police station she was
manhandled there now apparently first
the first charges that they wanted to
put on
javara is that she had assaulted a
female
israeli soldier but then because there
were all these videos
around and really the moment of her
detention was filmed from all sides
the lawyer showed that to the officer
and then those charges were dropped
and now the charge is that she didn't
make herself known she didn't identify
herself
the lawyer argued uh you know exactly uh
who she is uh javara has been
a journalist here for many years she's
been going to
on a nearly daily basis or at least each
time
there's some sort of protest happening
there and today i
saw her while she was doing her job we
were covering
a small protest she was wearing the flak
jacket she had written press
on the front on the back she was holding
a microphone with the al jazeera logo
so it was very clear who she was now
we're waiting to see
if she's going to be released tonight if
she's going to spend and
she's going to spend the night at the
police station if she's going to
be released on conditions or not we
still don't know what we know
that at the moment there's an
investigation going on and she's being
interrogated
right and obviously we've been seeing
this uh footage which is a
clear demonstration of what took place
hodder i know that you have also
spoken to other people that were
witnesses uh in
in shekhirah who saw what took place
tell us more about what people have been
saying to you today and of course the
the whole reason that javara was there
the story that she was there to
to report on
well we were all there to report on a
protest in support of the families who
are threatened
of forceful eviction from their homes
now this protest actually oddly enough
uh had been we stood there for about an
hour and a half and it was very peaceful
usually uh the israeli military has
very little patience with any kind of
protest
by palestinians and usually the
crackdown is quite swift
it did not happen today javara was there
doing her job speaking to people
so and there was no reason for any of
that to happen but we have noticed
uh over the past few weeks that the
israeli security forces have
less and less patience for journalists
they don't like journalists to be there
around especially if you're reporting in
occupied east jerusalem if you're in
west jerusalem
which actually i went to a protest just
after chef jarrah i went to a protest in
west jerusalem
that was in front of the house of the
prime minister well over there you don't
see any of these
security forces in full riot gear
all you see is a couple of traffic
police standing there idly letting the
protesters express themselves when
you're in occupied east jerusalem well
that
sort of uh you're not really allowed to
express yourself
and journalists have been targeted
lately our own cameraman
was sort of fired with a stun grenade
yesterday as we were filming the arrival
of some marathon runners
in silhouette there the crackdown was
quite brutal
and we have seen this footage online of
journalists working for
other international news channels that
have been
uh manhandled in their contact with
israeli police holder but
it's uh really palestinian journalists
that that bear
the brunt of this sort of treatment
absolutely it is palestinian journalists
who have the brunt of this treatment
they have
files they're being profiled they they
can also be sitting at home
and then the police can arrive there and
detain them from their own home
it's completely different they also get
less
media coverage but yes definitely it is
the palestinian
journalists who bear the brunt of that
whether it's here
in occupied east jerusalem in the in the
occupied west bank or even in gaza i
mean
last year or two years ago during those
protests along the border fence with
gaza several
journalists were specifically targeted
targeted by israeli snipers so they have
it really really hard
thank you so much appreciate it
abdulhamid reporting us
reporting to us from occupied east
jerusalem thank you hodder
well earlier we have from sabrina benue
a spokeswoman for reporters without
borders and
she says that the israeli government is
trying to silence journalists
well reporters without borders denounces
a clear
obstacle to the right to inform this is
a clear violation of press freedom
because
this journalist was clearly recognizable
as she was wearing a press vest
and there is a clear will from the
israeli authorities to prevent
journalists
from doing their job and from reporting
on the ground
um we think that these
images were very shocking of brutality
and
this is clearly unacceptable and if um
if this journalist is jailed he will be
the 14th journalist to be killed by the
israeli authorities because there are
other
13 journalists palestinian journalists
who are now
uh detained by the israeli authorities
with unclear charges
usually it's incitement against israel
and with the reports of
the administrative detention it exempts
the israeli
the israeli authorities from giving
official charges
and it allows them to prolong the
detention
again and again and there are other
journalists just like her
who can be detained very long very long
month month and month and uh there is
her place is certainly not in jail but
uh she should freely exercise as a
journalist and
report what's occurring on the ground
it's a clear obstacle
right to journalists to jail with no
official charge
it means that they can be kept in jail
again and again
and um they can stay in jail and they
in the meantime they cannot report and
um
the fact is that the israeli authorities
um
don't have um are not uh forced
to um to uh provide
um you know the the all the motives of
the
of the arrests they say that uh it is
linked with the
the israeli intelligence and uh it
should be kept confidential so this is
why it can take
months and months and in the meantime
journalists are just prevented from
doing their job and as i told you there
are all
13 other journalists palestinian
journalists who are in jail at the
moment
and with no official charge